joining us once again on the programme
dr david nabarro the world health
organization special envoy for the
global covert 19 response dr nabarro
always good to see you and it it has
been a little while since we last
chatted which which usually means that
things have been going relatively well
with covid two years on from the first
domestic lockdown here in the uk
globally what's the picture like
well we still are in the middle of a
quite unpleasant pandemic
other things have dominated the news
recently but my quick summary is the
virus is continuing to move
there are still an awful lot of people
getting sick and dying each week
and we cannot be complacent i'd like to
ask everyone
do continue if you can to wear face
masks in crowded places do continue
to maintain physical distancing and if
you are vulnerable and that means if
you've got other diseases do please
shield yourself and the most important
way to do that is get vaccinated we're
living with the virus and it's still
causing a lot of problems
dr nabarro i don't know the last time
that you might have spent any amount of
time in london or anywhere else in
england right now
it doesn't feel
like anyone or very few people are
adhering to those recommendations and
they remain recommendations for the
government to keep our distance to wear
masks and crowded places
people aren't doing it
yeah i've noticed that interestingly i
don't
i mean i'm more of a time in france and
switzerland and i have to say
certainly in france people are being
remarkably careful i'm told by my
children that it's a different situation
in the uk
my only advice to everybody is
just don't forget remember that this has
killed so many people
and that it's still nasty i don't want
to get kobe and i don't think anybody
else should you know we're also learning
about long covid which is when you get
infected and you you think you're going
to get better and then you've got
several weeks of being unwell under the
weather unable to do what you want to do
here it is people are the solution to
this pandemic let's do what we can to
not let it get ahead of us again
i mean i was speaking to someone kind of
involved in the public health response
here in the uk you know a couple of days
ago but what does what does it look like
what does living with with covid 19
actually look like and they said look
it's going to be lots and lots of people
catching it some of those people getting
ill but
crucially very few people actually
losing their lives i mean is that what
living with covert looks like for you
i hope so but you know get to reach that
point and to stay there we have to all
be up to date on our vaccinations
after you've been vaccinated the
defenses in your body gradually fade and
for some people older people like me the
fading is a bit quick so i have to say
to everybody keep your vaccinations up
to date you should certainly have got
three and perhaps you should be thinking
about a fourth if you're in the older
community and so with that up-to-date
vaccination with being careful on not
exposing ourselves we'll live with kobed
uh but if from time to time we'll have a
few scares
dr nabarro i want to ask you about
something that i saw in the papers the
other day and another vaccine that is
being developed at the moment the
world's first plant-based acting they
were told the report suggested that the
who would reject that vaccine because
the company developing it is half owned
by the tobacco giant philip morris i
mean what is the truth of all of that
so i cannot answer that question okay
there are complexities there but i do
want to say to everybody new vaccines
are going to go on being developed from
lots of different sources and just we
need to be ready for real strides
forward in the whole area of vaccinology
including through the technology you've
described
just in terms of
testing do you still feel that mass
testing has a role in the western world
right now
well as i've said the virus is the
problem people are the solution you
can't solve the problem and live with
covert if you don't know where the virus
is and so if there's one thing i'd like
to ask all governments to try to
maintain that is easy access to testing
we always say that if the proportion of
people who test positive in a country
rises above about 10 percent then
there's not enough testing being done
there are many countries in europe where
there should be more testing done in
that way we know what's going on in that
way we keep ahead of the virus
dr david navarro always good to see you
hope you and yours are well thanks for
joining us